what's going on guys this is rob and
we're doing a spoiler-free review of
moon night episode one tomorrow we will
have the video with like all the easter
eggs and the spoilers and all that kind
of cool stuff
so here's the thing um
moon knight feels a little bit different
than i thought it would but i absolutely
love it uh it is it is just
great there was no point over the first
episode when i was bored i think that's
probably one of the more important
things there was no point where i was
really bored when it came to the show um
i thought it was just interesting and
riveting from start to finish um i will
say that like the inner monologue that
they had over the course of that show it
gave me some really really strong like
eddie brock and venom vibes from like
the sony venom film but i loved it i
also love the way that like the
switching personalities was depicted now
i don't know anybody who has
disassociative identity disorder i don't
know anyone with that so i have no idea
how that process takes place i'm curious
to see i might look up a youtube video
to see what it's like with a person who
has a disassociative identity disorder
but i feel like it would be fascinating
to educate myself on that and to learn
more about it having said that uh over
the course of the show there were some
great moments there were some great
references there's one where i don't
know if they directly reference what i'm
thinking of in terms of a location but
if it's where i think it is
[Music]
yeah that's that's a video for tomorrow
there's a video for tomorrow um great
little easter eggs great little
references um i love the character
development i love the dynamic this is
by no means a spoiler but arthur harrow
who would put like glass in his shoes
and then walk on them uh that's wildly
intriguing right that's wildly
interesting to me i'm curious to see if
that's going to have any significance
later on down the line because that's
kind of a big thing to do and then not
offer any explanation for it uh that's
that's kind of wild so i loved the way
that oscar isaac portrayed steve grant i
love the steve grant character it's just
it's so just i mean i want to say fun
but at the same time his life kind of
sucks
so i don't know if i would say the way
he portrays him is fun but you know what
i mean like it's interesting it's really
really interesting and really really
intriguing so i love that whole thing i
love the slight invocation of like the
mythos with enough of us uh really
leaving enough out for us to be
intrigued and to want to see more
overall it was a phenomenal first
episode it was straight and it was to
the point it gives you some mystery and
it gives you some intrigue but it also
makes you wonder what else is going on
behind the scenes how else are things
unfolding i will say what i was
expecting to a degree because i've been
reading moonlight for a long long time
and so what i was expecting was maybe
some combination of the old like moon
knight fists of conscious stories or
maybe like jeff lemire's run or
something along those lines or possibly
even uh really more recently like judd
mckay i was expecting that um we didn't
really get that we didn't really get
that exact depiction of moon knight um
instead it's it's a combination of some
things that we've seen in the comics
there were a couple stories that the the
creator came out and said were like just
highly influential i think it was the
director came out and said was highly
influential for the moon night show but
all in all it's a combination of
elements from the moon knight mythos and
i think that that's kind of to be
expected right that's to be expected i
mean you look at wanda vision that's a
combination of elements right it's a
combination of one division volume two
we're really vision and scholar witch
vol 2 by steve englehart not the old
bill mantlow for issue one but the steve
steve engelhardt 12 issue run right and
it is um the oh my god the scarlet witch
solo series by something robinson i can
never remember their their whole name uh
but that series like the one was like
it's like the white background with like
the red design of scarlet witch and the
arts really funky that kind of thing uh
it's it's basically that uh and a couple
other stories right it's like some
avengers stories tossed in different
things like that you know with a with a
pinch of house of him
but uh but you know it's one of those
things where in the mcu at this point we
don't really get like a particular
character story arc manifested in film
form that's not really how that works i
mean even with infinity war in avengers
end game that was a combination of
avengers forever as well as uh was it
the infinity gauntlet and then like a
smattering of infinity war minus the the
cosmic cube and then like the original
cosmic cube saga with captain marvel it
had all those little elements right
little elements from all those different
things all thrown into that movie so
it's it's it's kind of intriguing
because i know there are still people
out there who approach or who are going
to approach the moon night show from the
perspective of like i want to see a run
from muna right a character arc like a
six issue story arc manifested in this
show honestly i think that would drag it
down to be quite frank you know this
show was this episode was just great and
i gotta say man if this is the future
because as we know when it comes to
marvel cinematic universe shows the
first show is the tip of the iceberg
right like
there's no telling what's going to
happen over the course of this show
literally the loki show picked up with
loki being snatched up by the tva
because of the fact that he had
essentially grabbed the the tesseract
and disappeared in the first avengers
movie by the time this show ends they
killed some version of kang the
conqueror and the multiverse came back
so there's nowhere i guess the
multiverse expanded right it already
been back it expanded so there's no
telling where in the hell this show is
going to go
[Laughter]
that being said and and this isn't
really a spoiler for the show um that
being said i am really hoping just based
on the comic mythos this will in some
form or fashion segue or give us a
post-credit scene or some kind of teaser
that will indicate the arrival of the
midnight suns i'm really really hoping
that happens and and here's the reason
why the midnight suns is something that
we haven't really seen before we know we
already have blade he was the voice we
heard in the post credits scene of
eternals spoiler for a movie that nobody
really likes too much uh and then moon
knight of course was a long-standing
member of the midnight suns i haven't
seen morbius yet so i don't know how
that movie fits into the greater
you know marvel cinematic universe if it
does i don't know adrian toomes is there
i'm hearing mixed things i'm hearing
things from different directions right
and none of them make any sense so i
have no idea
i have no idea what's going on there
doctor strange led the midnight suns at
one point in time we know that robbie
reyes was an agent of shield which i
think the agents of shield continuity is
like murky at best so i'm not really
sure if it even fits into the marvel
cinematic universe anymore and if it
doesn't i don't know i don't know how
that's the case because literally the
leader of the agents of shield is a guy
who was in the avengers and died you
know so he's kind of like
that just confirms continuity i guess i
don't know um regardless you know there
we've seen different characters appear
in some form or fashion whether it's a
voice or just a full on-screen
appearance we've seen characters appear
in the mcu up to this point that have
had ties with the midnight suns and so i
would love it if this kind of segues
into it even if it doesn't right even if
it doesn't a huge influence in this
episode was mark's disassociative
identity disorder again i loved the way
they handled it i love the way that they
depict it i don't know how accurate it
is but i love the cinematic view and the
sort of cinematic visual of how his
disassociative identity disorder
manifested right i absolutely loved that
whole thing and so i'm really hoping
they focus more into that what i'm
hoping they don't do over the course of
this show i'm hoping they don't do what
bendis did right so for those of you
guys who don't know brian michael
bennett is a comic book writer it's he
over complicates things the whole idea
is that back in the early moon night
stories it was believed that mark
spector had schizophrenia
because you didn't know if like kanchu
was real if like khanshu's appearance to
him were real or anything along those
lines it was one of those things where
like maybe maybe he just can't
differentiate between reality and
fantasy over the years it's been
confirmed kanchu is real he was actually
given powers by khanshu uh and that it's
not really a schizophrenic thing but i'm
hoping the show does not invoke that and
if they if it does it's just slightly
touching on it but the mental illness
that that mark specter you know
struggles with right now is
disassociative identity disorder so i
would rather they very much focus on
that but i'd rather they very much focus
on that element because that alone makes
this character phenomenal like in jeff
lemire's run like with his personalities
mark spector jake lockley and steve
grant basically in that run he had to
like confront all of his personalities
and merge them as opposed to like
ignoring them because that's what caused
his disassociative identity disorder and
his did is that he was ignoring those
personalities and they kept trying to
show up right they kept trying to make
themselves known they literally had a
mind of their own and so by merging them
all together then he was a whole
personality again until he wasn't but
the thing is is like
that's what happened in jeffers run so
you know i think it'd be cool you know i
mean i'm curious to see how all this
stuff plays out but in terms of the
first show the first episode it was
phenomenal it was absolutely
mind-blowing so with that being said
guys uh tomorrow's video is gonna be the
spoiler one that's where we go through
all the easter eggs and all that kind of
stuff because for key night fans there's
more than a few things to be referenced
in this uh in this episode especially
location-wise there's definitely uh
yeah it's what i think it is i i hope
it's what i think it is with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this to an
end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later peace